hi everyone this is Steve want robe with
collider and I am here with max Winkler
for jungle and the poster right behind
you that's a guy like a fight poster at
this guy who I really love designed for
it who you know that that was gonna be
on the laptop when they show the poster
for the fight in the movie so we should
be clear it's not the actual post now
movie but I like it though I think you
know how'd you do it looks cool we were
looking like old polish like music
festival stuff from like like the 50s
and stuff and use that as a reference so
I normally don't do anything like
generic at the beginning of the
interview but everyone watching this
will not have seen your movie yet we're
just world premiered at the Toronto
International Film Festival
so what can you what have you been
telling people about the film that it's
it's sort of like a male melodrama about
these two brothers that have sort of
existed in this you know sort of their
own little universe for their whole
lives that kind of becomes upended when
a and they're forced to drive across the
country with a girl that they don't
really know and her existence sort of
highlights sort of the fissures in their
their own sort of extremely codependent
relationship and they kind of deal with
that there's a boxing element about the
movie too yeah there's definitely some
boxing yes just just a touch yes
bare-knuckle boxing though
sure but because I would never really
call the movie sort of like a boxing
movie or fighting movie but that's
definitely a tool used in the movie this
is for people that have seen your
previous films this is a complete
departure from what you've done in the
past I think yes me too and so what was
it about this material that said because
sometimes people you know do things that
gets hard for people to maybe get the
money together the financing when you
haven't done something like this before
was it tough for you to get this off the
ground well it was tough in this end
today written the original script for
this with my two co-writers Teddy
Bressman and David Branson Smith
started 10 years ago when I had done to
my first Toronto of my first movie
ceremony which is kind of like a
romantic screwball comedy and you know
to do sort of like of mice and men male
kind of drama like that I
wanted to do people thought it was crazy
and people thought I could never do it
for the amount of money that I wanted to
make it for and so I sort of waited and
then flour my second movie had kind of
come up in the middle of that and I made
flour which kind of had nothing to flour
was like a female you know sort of like
you know it in hopes of you know like
like a kitchen sink
female drama so that had nothing to do
with my first movie and then this all
three movies I think the connection is
it's like people really kind of
portraying one version of themselves to
the outside world where in the inside of
their lives they're kind of having like
a nervous breakdown of identity or
something like that so I've found now
that I have a sort of a body of work I
have three movies to try to find the the
through line between them what the what
the common experience isn't I think it
was that what listen your two leads who
are right up here they're incredible in
the movie yeah I think so too
and so talk a little about landing the
two of them because and was it tough
like talk a little bit about how it all
came together yeah we you know we had
gotten Charlie had read the script and
responded really strongly to it he'd
really liked that the movie I had made
previously and written a really nice
letter about it and so we met and
Charlie and I connected and the majority
of our first conversation was about the
anxiety of being a human being and how
can your past mistakes you know not
define who you are and can you continue
to push for it I ended up talking a lot
about Charlie's Guy Ritchie King Arthur
movie that I was obsessed with that he
had had you know we people kind of
reacted differently to it when it first
came out but I thought was an incredibly
underrated movie and simultaneously was
having a bad him insomnia where I wasn't
sleeping and I would watch King Arthur
every night because it was on and I
would send videos to my friends like
this movie's amazing I told a lot of
people that I even wrote the Lonely
Island who are some of my friends not to
name drop but I said you guys should
write a song about people who love this
kid Guy Ritchie King Arthur movie and
feel like no one sees them and that they
need a support group for it and they
were really into the idea
great and Charlie thought I was like
taking the piss out of him are making
fun of them or something like that is a
neuronal you don't understand I think
this is like a very important movie your
performance in it is nuanced and
beautiful I sent the final scene where
you fight Jude Law to my therapist and
asked if this person would written this
was a client because it's all about
facing her fear and knowing that your
fear is actually what defines you and
stuff I'd really kind of found inherent
in the Stanley Kaminsky character the
Charley plays and Jack you know I'd seen
him in 71 I'd seen Jack in start up and
I was a massive fan of his and I knew
that he had done a little bit of boxing
in his past which I thought was a
necessary ability in order to shoot the
fight stuff the way I wanted to shoot it
without the budget of teaching somebody
had a box and you know in a three month
period of time and we we had dinner the
three of us and immediately sort of some
brother type tendencies had kind of
shown themselves just in Charlie's age
and the difference between them and you
know their chemistry their the way they
come across on screen is is literally
just by them being good actors like we
didn't spend a lot of time at all with
the two of them together we didn't do
one of those actor boot camps we didn't
do those things where we send them off
into Fall River to live for five months
and and drink their own well water like
it was really just the two of them being
authentic on set every day sure it's so
interesting have you have you ever had
that kind of reaction to a performance
like that because it's you know we're
like because you clearly reacted to King
Arthur it clearly had a thing that
affected you yeah has that happened to
you before with another performance yes
but in in more indifferent movie you
know like in five Easy Pieces you know
training in the last detail or you know
the deer hunter you know stuff like that
or you know the first time I saw
Rushmore Bottlerocket
like I think Charlie was caught off
guard that I was having this type of an
authentic experience to King Arthur
which had just lost Warner Brothers a
lot of money and you know you know when
that happens people seem to only think
about the bottom line and not the actual
quality of the movie which I thought was
really really good
listen I keep on going on and on like I
there are very few like everyone talks
about making sequels and to to
everything like everyone to do a sequel
there are very few movies that I
actually would like pay money in advance
to get made I use Master and Commander
as one of them that movies a masterpiece
but well why wouldn't you because it's a
phenomenal elevator where yeah the movie
it hurts me every day that I see that
film and it doesn't have a sequel but
for me like that's an example of you
know you wanted there to be a sequel of
King Arthur no I wanted a sequel of
Master Command what in there talks about
that yeah the problem was the movie
costs too much money so it made money
but it didn't make enough compared to
the budget it's sort of like remember
John Carter of course okay so if that
movie didn't cost two hundred million
dollars they would have made a sequel
but the movie cost a crazy amount of
money it wasn't a bomb and made hundreds
of millions of dollars but not enough to
justify a sequel at a cost sure you know
I love I love Master and Commander and I
love Peter Weir I think he's such a
diverse incredible director I completely
agree the ending of Truman Show is like
an intravenous shot of just emotion into
my bloodstream when he's talking to Ed
Harris and sure threat guy kills me ya
know I mean he again he's what we call a
talented filmmaker yeah truly you know a
little bit he's done one or two things
um so one of the interesting things
about this is you filmed this in
Massachusetts at least you're very
familiar way I am very familiar but at
the Toronto Film Festival at the at the
at the world premiere you guys talked
about how like the scene would have
nobody like you you're a camera at them
it's just the two of them and then what
you're not seeing is behind the camera
there's like a thousand people watch a
thousands and thousands of people that
that could not believe that Jack's from
Sons of Anarchy was was in their town
and I'd never I'd never really seen a
celebrity like this in such a such a way
you know we would he would get followed
home I mean he really is like sort of a
cultural icon because of this show
especially to American people who have
named their children after him and have
his face tattooed on them and their dogs
are named after him and the craziest
thing is he's from the north of England
yeah but he's it was
really gnarly too because we weren't
prepared we didn't have like the
security detail and stuff and eventually
we had to have like decoy cars drive you
know outside the house when when Charlie
was leaving so people couldn't follow
him home which was shocking and made it
really hard to shoot because I'd never
been used to I was I've always been sort
of like you know grabbed the camera with
my DP let we were set to shoot over
there let's go shoot over there but we
really couldn't because we were getting
followed everywhere and the first day of
shooting we used our camera test day as
a way to shoot the opening titles in the
movie which is one of my favorite parts
of the movie and I thought it was gonna
be this really easy thing and then all
of a sudden one kid on a bike says yo
there's Jax and the second kid on the
bike calls somebody and then within
minutes there's thousands and thousands
of people out there waiting for Charlie
and it was really quite a sensation yeah
it's it's crazy
yeah crazy well also Massachusetts you
don't get like huge movie stars or huge
stars you know in Fall River no
definitely not I mean I there never been
a movie shot in Fall River we were
shooting in Fall River New Bedford
Taunton rain and and these places you
know were you know at at a point in the
world you know the wealthiest cities in
the entire world based on textiles based
on whaling and have since fallen into
sort of depressive times as far as the
workforce goes and I loved shooting
there I love the people there we turned
you know an old you know sort of
broken-down greyhound dog racing track
basically like into our you know budget
Pinewood like we had you know we turned
it we said you know our stages up there
we did holding there we shot you know 15
different locations for across the
country in this greyhound track and it
was bizarre
I mean the energy is weird but yeah did
it help you look people are always
challenged to try to find extras in you
were some boxing scenes did it help
having them without a doubt yeah we had
great extras we had this guy named Billy
who did our forgot his last name
Billy Dowd an incredible local casting
director and he found us unbelievable
background actors and everyone had an
interesting face and and maneuver you
know actors who only have two lines were
incredible I loved the whole experience
of being there there's a great
Portuguese market there we would always
eat at called Portugal yeah I'm always I
remember the food on when I get to visit
movie sets yes it's the only thing I
remember it's it's like out from
everything else right um I love talking
about the editing room because
ultimately that's the final rewrite so
you get in the editing room with all
your footage how did what excited you
and what made you nervous
the performance is excited me I knew
leaving there that at the very least the
actors would be fine and if anybody
became blackballed it would be me
I knew the actors were great what I was
concerned about was I know if I I'd
never directed fighting before and I
really didn't think I was gonna be able
to do it like I you know we had a plan
and we watched Raging Bull and we
watched Olly and we watched rust and
bone and my DP and my editor and I were
reversed on what we went for and how we
wanted to create each fight scene is
something else and I was really nervous
that we weren't gonna be able to make it
work because we just didn't have the
time I mean jungle and we shot and what
the final fight we shot in one and a
half days and the rest of them we shot
half days or a day and for people that
don't realize we're watching this that's
just not a lot of time no it's not a lot
of time and and actually the fights I've
ended up working out I was really happy
with it I thought because we didn't have
stunt people and you know I was really
proud of of being able to be on Jack's
face for that that whole time and really
getting to see how incredibly physical
he is as an actor which I had seen again
and start up you know and you know as a
perfect example and yeah one of the
things that and again I want to go back
to the the world premiere Charlie got
very emotional talking about how how how
he felt you captured a really honest
portrayal like he was really just honest
on the screen and he really almost was
getting choked up I mean and he's worked
with a lot of people what is
mean for you when you know you're lead
like that or your co-lead has that kind
of reaction it meant a lot to me I got
choked up to hearing how proud he was of
himself because he's so hard on himself
and and the only work I had to do with
him as an actor on set was to tell him
just to go easier on himself because he
he he's a perfectionist and you know he
gets he gets cast in these leading man
roles a lot and what I love of him in
this movie is he really is a subtle
really gentle actor when he can play
sort of like the ratso Rizzo part
instead of the King Arthur part Turner
and he was you know we cut his hairline
back and he lost so much weight and he
was so he was so sensitive to to his
other actors and to the filmmaking part
of it and I just his performance is one
of the things in my you know short
career that I'm the most proud of yeah I
was gonna say that the other thing about
this is you're making a road movie with
not a lot of days not a lot of money
you're making a boxing movie not a lot
of days not a lot of money and so did
you say I just want to make the most
challenging thing I can I'm an idiot
like I never make it easy on myself
flour we shot for five hundred thousand
dollars and and that was you know the
scope of that was you know a quixotic I
always want to say key codec but its
quixotic I think I yeah it was it was
crazy I mean I I i wanted to make a road
movie without cutting away so i knew
it's just creatively before we even got
into budget cutting i wanted to make a
road movie where you don't cut to a wide
shot of the Grand Canyon and see the car
driving by like I felt like we could
show scope somewhere in a different way
and yeah it was it was ambitious but the
good news about that part of the world
you know we shot we shot in Reno we shot
in San Francisco but the majority of our
time was in New England and and there's
such beautiful locations there I made it
really easy on our production designer
because the the locations are the sets I
mean they were perfect and it helped
everyone get into the mood creatively
and
yeah scot-free productions yeah were
they I guess they've helped produce yes
they produced it Ridley and Kevin and
Ryan and stolen Kevin Walsh Brian stolen
jewels daily how did you connect with
them because it's a big company to have
on your movie yeah they were amazing
Jules Daly who had run RSA for years
which is the Ridley Scott agency it's
the the commercial arm of their company
and she signed me for commercials off of
flour and you know we had been talking
and I sort of loosely pitched this to
her and she said you know maybe I'll
read it and I sent the script to her and
within you know the script had been
around for 10 years various people tell
me why it's impossible to make and Jules
Daly was the one who said no I know how
to make this and brought it into
scott-free and that's when Kevin and
Ridley and Ryan got involved and and the
movie got off the ground really really
quickly and everyone everyone and then
I'm Ridley Scott's one of my favorite
filmmakers of all time actually had
ironically my dad came to visit me in
the editing room and he reminded me that
early on in high school I'd was obsessed
with one Ridley Scott's movies called
white squall which is like a super
random without movie and I have like all
these signed headshots from like the
cast from white squall and like signed
soundtracks and signed scripts and I had
forgotten about that and and Ridley was
in the office that day and the three of
us were laughing about how bizarre the
world is that we were home hair together
it's interesting you definitely it
sounds like you get obsessed about
something go all in yeah and then until
the next obsession hits yes it's all
started with white squall
yeah West Side Story was very early on
for me it was probably my first
obsession I really like that and it
since has found its way to King Arthur
he's King Arthur I'm sure there's been
other things that what do you think
about spielberg redoing West Side Story
I think he'll probably be great
I heard he's okay too yeah he's been
he's got quite a track record I and
different and I think there's parts of
the I think West Side Story you know
between you know Robert Wise and Jerome
Robbins I think they're probably a
perfect movie but I think there's
probably things that you could do
differently just to see with that sort
of
experience was like you know potentially
casting actual latin american people as
the puerto ricans would probably be the
smart thing first
instead of Greek people but George
Chakiris is great obviously and I think
it'll probably be great yeah I am I'm
actually really looking forward to it
and I think that you know if any listen
I you're playing with a third rail with
a movie like that but but I if anyone
can do it it's him yeah and it's just
great to take risks and try [ __ ] and
just mess around and never know what can
happen he's such there's no one in the
history of the world that's ever moved
the camera like him even close I don't
think and I feel like he's gonna shoot
the dancing and they got that great
choreographer um I forgot his name I
think it's just in PEC maybe it's
something else but he's an amazing
choreographer and he did carousel and he
did you know all these beautiful ballets
if this is the person I'm thinking of
and I think they're probably just gonna
do an incredible job well the other
thing is anyone who landed that gig you
obviously grew up with the movie and
everyone it's not one of those movies
where people truthfully are doing it for
a paycheck I think it's if you're doing
that movie you genuinely want it to be
great yes you do jungle land for the
paycheck to do West Side Story was
Spielberg for the passion and love of it
right so when I go back to the editing
room answer what was the last scene that
you took out of the film before locking
your cut and why the last scene I took
out of the movie there's a scene of them
checking in to jungle land and there's
like this sort of like Vietnam veterans
sort of guy who was very early on in
casting that was obsessed with him
Kenji's man I'm gonna name check him
here because he did not get cut out of
the movie because of his performance he
got cut out of the movie because I was
so into his performance and had gone so
crazy by the end of shooting this that I
gave him like a really big part so like
after the insanity that there's this
movie they're finally checking into
jungle and we get into sort of like a
hamlet style monologue with the man
who's checking the men asking them if
they're ready for the fight and people
were left with some questions is why we
were focusing on a man who's in the
script named his old senior played by
the brilliant Ken Cheeseman and a
tie-dye Jungleland shirt that David
Branson Smith our writer does
and why we were focusing on this moment
when everything that came before it was
crazy what's gonna happen after it's
pretty crazy so Ken got the axe and his
performance was excellent even on set I
knew I was getting indulgent and crazy
by focusing on this character but I felt
like I deserved it after everything that
we had been through what is it like no
when you realized okay this is gonna be
getting cut out what is it like do you
pick up the phone and call people when
they when they're losing the thing are
you sort of like is that the direct like
are you sending an email like what do
you do because it must be an agonizing
thing I for this one I took I took this
I took this Collider interview to tell
Ken Cheeseman this for others you know
there's there's it's always hard but it
so rarely has to do with the actor you
know if I've done my job correctly and
I've cast the right people and I did in
this day I have I love everyone from
Jonathan majors to John columns Jessica
Barden I love them all and sometimes you
know when the movie becomes this sort of
organism it just doesn't work as well
because of faults of my own a section of
the movie that kind of became different
structurally was the first act because
we'd focus so much on their backstory we
were getting feedback from audiences
saying we get their backstory by the way
these two guys interact with each other
you don't need to over explain it so I
lost one of my favorite scenes of the
movie which was Jonathan majors sort of
playing pepper breaking down to Charlie
and Jack their history together and the
scene was brilliantly acted by Jonathan
majors it was in one of my favorite
locations which was in this old sort of
wall masada Club in New Bedford
Massachusetts and there were these giant
squids on the wall was amazing but it
didn't work because at that point in the
movie everyone's just waiting for these
guys to get on the road and you're
stopping and engaging in monologues
which is just my fault with the writing
and my fault with the staging and it
leave people just want to go so you know
I I it's always it's always hard and I
think the best thing the men she is
think you can do is just write them and
say just you know this has nothing to do
this is my own fault and I wrote
Jonathan major said we
to lose that of one of my favorite
scenes because it it and because of what
I just told you sure yeah
oh it's just I've strung in a lot of
directors and they always talk about
some people find out they lost their
parts at the premiere because they just
don't have the heart to tell them you
know it's just it's so interesting too
that feels that feels not right to me I
I agree but yeah I know I know someone
who had that had that happen to them and
and I'm gonna try to be better than that
yeah one of the things that the film
deals with is the American Dream but
from the like it focuses on people that
sometimes don't get focused on yeah
people really like these two are on the
the you know they are struggling right
you know and sort of talked about that
aspect of the film yeah I mean it this
idea like the American Dream does
everyone get a piece of it or is
everyone entitled to it you know you
have these like old sort of books that
were circulating in like 1900 to get
factory workers to feel good about
themselves at the horatio alger books
and like I feel like you know Charlie's
character you know got a little too high
off of them and and thinks that he's
sort of entitled to this thing without
any talent and without any skill
whatsoever except the his adjacency to
Jack's character who's the only one in
the film that really has this gift and
with that gift comes guilt of do I am I
do I deserve this do I want this and and
I really tried to to to portray that
sort of blind optimism of Charlie's as
as truthful honestly as we could and I
think Charlie's performance obviously
does the heavy lifting of that and makes
it really good you know but you were you
kind of meet all of these people who
have their own version of the dream
pepper has his version of the dream he's
kind of living it Jessica's character
Skye you know sort of talks about how
she wants this one part of the dream has
she always wanted to be something and it
didn't quite work out and has found
herself in a totally different situation
Charlie has this dream that he and his
brother gonna live in California and
have a house and his brothers gonna be a
professional fighter and they're gonna
have a sponsorship and clothing line and
all this stuff and we kind of know
Charlie's almost like you almost kind of
like
mama rose in gypsy we always saw him
more as a single mother than a than an
older brother you know really maternal
like energy really tactile really really
everything he does is to try and get
this this this person this other person
in the best position possible to succeed
by the and you know it's it comes at a
cost obviously because you want to
figure out you have this sort of thing
with you know in movies and in life with
parents you how much is your dream and
how much is it that you want this other
personal about their dream well one of
the things I liked about and again you
know almost everyone watching this will
not have seen the movie but and so I
don't want to do any sort of spoilers
but one of the things I really liked
about Charlie's character in it is that
he sort of acknowledges that that he is
not the most gifted person man he he
like sort of just figured out his place
and I liked that because often times in
movies everyone you know it's
unrealistic they think that they're the
the ace you know they're they're the a
storyline right he sort of knows you
know I'm the B storyline right you know
yeah I love that moment when he has that
bet he has that conversation with
Jessica's character sky and he sort of
says like I haven't really done anything
I'm not planning on an either exact I
don't have it like all I know is that
this guy's got something special and
I'll do everything in my power to
protect it and make sure that he uses it
to the best of his ability and yeah I
thought that was I thought I I'm glad
you brought that up because I thought
that I loved that scene the way they
acted that scene yeah it's like it's a
it's a really realistic moment and
someone who understands their place
right not like it can't change right but
you know I mean so I want to ask
so who random question who ruined the
most takes and why who ruined the most
takes or who flubbed the most takes and
why it's crazy we were really lucky on
on the act of renina probably ruined the
most takes just by either I you know I
was really trying to think all these
actors were so prepared there's really
not a lot of flubbing that went on
set and I've I've been on a lot of sets
where I've ruined takes by laughing and
I felt really guilty about it but no one
on this it was a really focused set goal
was really we didn't have a lot of time
we had a lot of scenes and we had a lot
of different locations and so we were
really quick and diligent I would say
the most frustrating people on set were
me and Damiano Garcia the
cinematographer because we were really
indecisive when we would get on set we
had a plan of what we wanted and often
find that our plan was not what we
thought it was gonna be especially with
a thousand people watching yes and so we
would change our minds often we would we
would start to shoot we would get ready
to make a shot and then Dom me I would
start to do that sort of baseline
soundtrack sound from from Seinfeld
whenever you can see an establishing
shot like mouth but now just like we
should be we should redo this shot it
looks like it's a sitcom establishing
shot so I would say it was probably
damiana and I that were the most time
sure what TV show would you love to
guest write and direct then is the new
Sopranos a show or a movie
it is a prequel movie right if they
decided to do a television show based on
that III think about The Sopranos
probably every day I think about The
Sopranos and the Beatles probably every
day we found the other two obsessions
right there's so many more I went to the
same thing with the wire I think about
The Sopranos every day I think that as
far as character studies go is probably
the most incredible exploration of a
really really complicated human being
and also that show did it before that
was one of the shows that ushered in the
golden age of television yeah it was
ahead of the curve in terms of what it
was doing yeah I would say that in the
Larry Sanders show if they ever if they
ever redid that somehow without Gary
we're probably and or The Sopranos
without again nothing I wouldn't
recommend it because those guys are the
heartbeat at that shows but and I those
are my favorite shows I'm not I'm not so
caught up on I love to show Jessa's on
on the end of the [ __ ] world I still
haven't seen the oh you'll you would
love it I've
everyone raves and but that actually cuz
I know we were talking about how it's
hard to watch TV that actually you can
finish in a day like you can really burn
through sure I mean the the toughest
part and I'm sure you hear it too is
you're constantly being told you should
watch that show it's just like it's why
what show are you being told to watch
the most I'm halfway through flea bag
that's incredible bro everyone raved I'm
sure man have you started the second
season no bang I finished the first
recently the second season will really
make it all click - that would be the
Madeline cookie where you're like oh
right this is an actual everyone says
the second season is even better
yeah that and yeah I also really want to
direct like a period drama like a BBC
period drama okay so that I think is
probably the best answer to your
question because those shows really get
made every year and like I would do like
you know like a Howards End or like a
Pride and Prejudice or like some sort of
a Jane Austen thing you think Kubrick's
Napoleon ever gets made um I don't know
I know Kubrick's Napoleon doesn't get
made but but no but good yeah all that
prep work he has a script exists he has
all that stuff and I wonder now in this
day and age with all these streaming
channels and all these people looking
for content if someone would have the
balls to say let's do it I'm sure
someone will yesterday that they want to
remake the Princess Bride yeah that's
the worst idea I've ever heard I can't
I'm not down with that I'm not I don't
know if and by the way I'm down with
remakes me too I think you can do it I
think there's good versions of remake
sure does Princess Bride is one of my
all-time favorite films and I'm not down
with it meaning like I'm just not and
that one like that idea needs to know I
just I just can't like the only
interesting version of that is if it's
if it's told if if if Wallace Shawn is
tucking in his sick
oh no Wallace Shawn is dead in the movie
but I'm interested in Wallace Shawn
playing the Peter Falk character and
whoever Wallace Shawn's grandson in is
playing the Fred Savage character okay
that's a twist that I had not thought
about but it's just such a perfect movie
you know it's a ten out of ten yeah it's
really silly to watch it whenever I was
sick at home
every guess I'm sure everyone has
everyone ring which leads me on my next
question what movie have you seen the
most movie have I seen the most probably
et or there will be blood you're hunter
right that is not the two movies that I
thought you would say that went together
easy I'm like yeah that makes sense
there will be blood wasn't expect much
more probably in Fast Times at Ridgemont
High sure hook I saw like multiple
multiple multiple times in the theater
at the city walk I remember as a kid I
call it the shitty walk yeah oh my god I
haven't been there in a while yeah and
there's a good reason not to go um
unless I just had to have my birthday at
the Bubba Gump there but yeah I saw hook
there multiple times and I just I just
want to see you having a birthday party
at the public embouchure I think I'll
probably do it next year right
everything goes according to plan oh
yeah what's that to just blow it all up
wait what what's funny is like at this
moment if you did a birthday party there
it could actually be cool because oh
probably it's so different you think I
could get them to sponsor it bubble gum
yeah if you bring Charlie yes right you
can get anyone to sponsor anything if
you bring charm I think that that that's
the secret I am curious I absolutely
love Barry just yes Tim can you watch
that show and like see is that weird for
you to watch no it's weird for me to
watch like happy days it's on waiting
for me to watch Barry yeah happy days I
could see like watching Barry is is is
he's to me and I've always felt this way
I felt like my dad as wonderful as his
career was was like this unbelievable
underused kind of treasure and I felt
like whoever got to him first would reap
the rewards whether it was Wes Anderson
PT Anderson the Coen Brothers Spike
Jones like whoever had the brilliance to
cast him in something weird and
off-brand and not as sort of like the
avuncular Jewish guy I think would would
be looked at as a genius and I think
Bill Hader was the one who got there and
I think it's just a brilliant off
casting
and and I think my dad is so good in it
because of the script and because of how
well it's directed and and it's not
weird for me cuz I'm kind of just like
this is what I was saying you know I
mean for our first years I'm just to say
like I think it's one of the best shows
on TV you need to in love it
and season two is unbelievable me to
like build such a great director I think
I completely agree there's a few
episodes in season two that are like
jaw-dropping yeah and there's some
monologues in season two that I'm like I
mean this is unbelievable yeah they're
geniuses I went to high school and
college with Hiro Mirai so it's amazing
to watch him and my dad work together
yeah I I have no I mean if you're not
watching Barry I strongly recommend
watching yeah he's amazing in it and and
I love watching it because I feel like
he's living his full potential as an
actor now at 70 whatever he is I don't
know how old he is exactly but in the
70s yeah I mean first of all props
second of all I saw one of my last
things so obviously this premiered at
TIFF yes for people that want to see it
yeah I think there'll be some sort of
news at some point about hoping for
today when does this get released this
will be online in the coming days within
yeah days we have we have really nice
some offers and feel really lucky about
that cuz everyone's talking about how
scary it is to make movies like this and
how hard it is to release them and I'm
hoping well we'll have it all wrapped up
by the time this comes out and they'll
be out this year what do you know what
you're gonna do next
dude I'm messing around with a with a
couple of things there's this there's
this movie that I didn't write and that
I was thinking about making Will Ferrell
I bet this guy who embezzle is a bunch
of money from the Colin street fruitcake
factory it's based on a real story and
it's a really insane story and I really
wanted to work with him for a long time
I love well me too and it's a really
dramatic part for him I think he'll be
amazing in it and a couple of a couple
of other things I wrote a Western with
with my frequent kind of collaborators
great writer and director named Matt
Spicer that I want to make very much
called heart of stone so that might be
another one like jungle and that takes
ten years to make because there's not a
lot of people throwing their hands in
the air to make up to pay for a Western
but yeah those are the two movies that I
am the most excited about right now
cool listen I wish you nothing but the
best I feel the same way about you know
couldn't go
Congrats on this and hopefully it will
be coming out soon and we can sit at the
ArcLight and do this again I can't wait
cool on that note a jungle land will at
some point you'll be able to see it and
until then watch Barry